what's going on with chicken nuggets
there's a chicken nugget story in the
news people are angry about their
nuggets
people are always going to chicken
nuggets oh they're poisoned oh we know
we know it's poison
what's happening McDonald's found liable
for Hot Chicken McNugget that fell from
Happy Meal and burned girl
there's nothing in this country better
than having a good scam
there's nothing better in this country
than having a good con
Fort Lauderdale Florida
of course
McDonald's and a franchise holder are at
fault after a Hot Chicken McNugget from
a Happy Meal fell on a little girl's leg
and Jesus caused a second degree burn a
jury in South Carolina has found
a second jury will determine how much
McDonald's USA and its franchise owner
Upchurch foods will pay the child and
her mother
Thursday's decision was split with
jurors finding the franchise holder
liable for negligence and failure to
warn customers about the risk of hot
food
how hot was this nugget it just was a
fiery Little Nugget that fell on this
girl or did the mother
the desperate mother
take the Nugget did A desperate mother
take a nugget in a car I want you to
Picture This a mother who's had enough a
mother who can't get ahead
a mother who knows
that things don't get better that's
movie [__]
she burns the Nugget with a lighter gets
it really hot and then presses it
against her daughter's leg I think
that's the only way this happens
philana Holmes testified that she bought
happy meals for her son and daughter in
a drive-through window to McDonald's in
Tamarack near Fort Lauderdale the south
Florida Sun Sentinel reported
she said she handed the food to her
children who are in the back seat after
she drove away her daughter started
screaming no none of this happened the
mother testified she didn't know what
was wrong until she pulled over to help
the girl identified in court as Olivia
the newspaper reported she saw the burn
on the girl's leg and took photos from
her eye no this is
now listen baby mommy has to hurt you
right now
mommy has to hurt you but you know that
Mommy loves you mommy would only ever
hurt you if she had to right
yes yes Mommy
now it's gonna hurt a little bit when I
put this McNugget I lit up on your leg
you understand that and you go scream
and that's okay you can scream loud
but mommy's gonna get you something
beautiful after this okay
it's lights the Nugget
the lighter
and she said this is what it's come to
you know this is this is if you want to
get ahead this is what it's come to
you know Florida the land of the free
and you're lighting the Nugget and then
when that Nugget's so damn hot she's
probably holding the Nugget with like
something else because her fingers can't
even touch it so she's holding the
Nugget and the Nuggets like I'm just
like [__] nuts
and then she just goes before she even
has the chance to like
you know not do it before she has the
chance like second guess it she goes
and the girl goes and the girl just
because it's so she's branding her
daughter with a nugget and then she and
then she goes okay now we're gonna Sue
because there's no way by the way
there's no way
this is the way things work okay unless
the kids are [__] no one picks up a
bag of nuggets and goes like this
and I would say this
if I was in court I would go okay so
what okay
the benefit of the doubt that okay
your daughter gets the Nugget back
and she goes like this
no you reach into the Nugget bag if
anything your daughter feels how hot it
is goes [__] me
I'm not eating that and the only Birds
would be on her fingers not her [__]
leg and then the mother's not getting
nervous she's like it's a color they're
going forensic on this they're going
forensic on it's pretty good but I'll be
honest I'm a man who's been let's just
let's not lie to anyone I've been to
McDonald's
now when you go to McDonald's and you
get nuggets and I throw it in nuggets
every now and then as a novelty they're
not even good it's just something to eat
in between it's like instead of just
breathing you have nuggets when you go
to McDonald's order I usually get like a
filet of fish and a quarter pounder and
then in between eating instead of just
the breath that you would take you throw
a nugget in to just keep it keep it
going now
there's no way there's no everybody
reaches in you open the Nugget see the
nuggets are in a thing you open them you
open the nuggets
and he select a nugget and then a lot of
times you don't get in the sauce now
maybe kids are not using the sauce which
may have cooled the Nugget down maybe
the kids are not using the sauce right
now
but there's no way the kids are just
dumping the food on themselves that's
crazy right well you don't have kids
that's actually what they do [__]
kids
dumb kids do that smart kids do not just
take a whole bag of food a whole happy
meal and go
let people go well they dump it out to
get the toy yeah but they don't do they
dump it on themselves
and even if they did that the nuggets
the Nuggets I guess one nugget is so hot
none of the other nuggets rap but
there's one molten nugget
this is the claim the claim is that
maybe the daughter's excited oh there's
a Happy Meal toy and she dumps it out
okay because this is what the other
attorney will say and the judge by the
way wants to kill himself the judge is
like
okay
all right
now you're saying that she was excited
about the toy so she did dump the food
on herself
okay
usually they pick the toy out of the bag
the first thing and I would object I'd
go objection honor
most children pick the toy out of the
bag first and they start playing with
the toy and the parents have to be like
you actually have to eat your food they
don't still no one dumps it on
themselves no one dumps the toy on
themselves that's [__] they want to
play with it they pick it out of the bag
they pick the toy out of the bag
well we have studies that show that kids
are excited they don't okay but whatever
you bring on your experts you bring on
your nugget
Happy Meal experts we'll bring on ours
get your experts will get us but the
reality is this hot nugget which I I do
believe the mother probably
either brought a hot nugget from home
that she had
and heated it up real hot or just
torched it in the car
to the point where she had to burn the
daughter's leg
the child who's autistic did not testify
well that's convenient
well that's uh convenient
my autistic daughter can't testify that
I burned her with a nugget
yeah of course she can't testify because
she'd tell everyone that you took a
nugget out of your purse
held it under a flame like you were
cooking a crack rock and then burned her
leg to get some money
she can't tell anyone that because she's
autistic
by the way everyone's autistic now this
is going to be a way everyone gets out
of everything I can't testify I'm
autistic
you just stabbed someone I hey I'm a
neurodivergent I can't uh testify I'm
very good with numbers though so if you
want to do any I could do that
the girl's parents sued saying the
McDonald's of the franchise uh didn't
train employees failed to warn customers
about the dangerous temperature of food
and cooking the food too much to a
higher temperature while both sides
agree in the Nugget caused the burns
the family's lawyers argued the
temperature was about 200 degrees while
the defense said it was no more than 160
degrees
what a bad defense
what a horrible defense McDonald you're
arguing about 40 degrees of nuggets how
about how about no this [__] burned her
daughter
how do you have a 200 degree nugget
can that happen I guess it can a 160
degree listen to this in a well-known
case from the early 1900s Stella live
x79 of Albuquerque New Mexico student
McDonald's over hot coffee that's built
on her lap in the car she received
significant injuries requiring
hospitalization and skin grafts well
that we understand but it's also like
it's hot coffee
yeah I remember this is what people
talked about in the 90s you know and it
was obviously it broke broke down
politically
you know the Libby Libs were like give
her the money [__] stop trying to
hurt people and the conservatives were
like it's hot coffee don't spill it on
your leg
you're supposed to drink it
now can you get up the McDonald's story
about the kid that choked on the
mozzarella stick that's why they no
longer have mozzarella sticks which I
this is what I've been led to believe
mozzarella sticks and McDonald's were
great and then one kid ruined it by
choking on it and dying and now if
you're again I I really believe is that
well what happened
the last okay the sticks are filled with
the substance that is composed what yeah
this is they they proved that they
weren't mozzarella cheese but no one
cares yeah that's not it okay no one
cared about that I think a kid choked on
I could be wrong about this but I I
seemingly remember
that during
the early 2000s I mean getting a
McDonald's mozzarella sticks with a
little marinara was lovely and then I
think someone died a teenager who
stopped breathing and passed out after
she choked on her McDonald's was saved
by a good cinema okay that's not yeah oh
wait hold on yeah
Charlotte Pape 17 had part of a
mozzarella Dipper it's called a stick
mozzarella stick Lodge in the throat
after she had a diabetic seizure outside
the drive-through restaurant in Abigail
Wales whose fault is that
that has nothing to do with the price of
tea in China
and they've taken away mozzarella sticks
um because this [__] in Wales
got sick you know she had a seizure and
anyone having a seizure is going to
choke on whatever they have
but this is what I mean like
McDonald's puts up with a lot of [__]
from people
spilling coffee on themselves choking on
mozzarella sticks during seizures
and burning their kids with nuggets I I
there's something going on here with
this
unless they gave this [__] 200 degree
nugget but still the burn should be on
the fingers
ow not on the leg
it says it got stuck in between the seat
belt that's what it was what yeah it
says right here it says that uh the
Nuggets were not meant to be pressed
between a seat belt and human flesh for
more than two minutes wait a minute
wait one [__] minute
the Nuggets were not meant to be present
between the seat belt and human flesh
for more than two minutes
so the hot nugget
somehow
gets between the seat belt and this
[__] for two minutes
now let's
mommy has to hurt you right now
do you want a pony
do you want to live on a farm do you
want all the bicycles in the world
because if you do mommy has to burn you
right now
mommy has to burn you bad and it's gonna
hurt
but mommy loves you and I'm telling you
she took the Nugget it's what I would
have done if I needed money no truly
if I needed money and I had an autistic
child I would burn them with a nugget
if I listen to me if I lived in Tamarack
Florida and I was nearing the end of
options
and I had an autistic child
and I'm sure they're fun for a little
bit but it gets a lot right
I'm just saying it probably does
and if I had if I and I'm thinking of
ideas because you know this mother was
thinking of ideas all night going like I
don't want to kill her I'm not going to
Casey Anthony or I'm not gonna throw in
a backpack put her in the lake but I
wanna I need to get a little money and
she's looking at this girl going she's
not going to go on The Voice
you know it's fun when your kids like a
little bit of a star either as an
athlete or a performer and you're like
maybe they'll get me out of this dump
you know you take them to competitions
and they're like well I am and you're
like [__] yeah everybody's like your
kid's a star I'm like hey hey damn right
and but then you got this thing
and you go well she's not this is not
this ain't little Brittany here Saint
Britney Spears here we're not she's not
getting us out with her Talent God love
her she's a beautiful lady and we're
happy we have her ish kinda but
We're not gonna throw We're Not Gonna
Kaylee We're Not Gonna Kaylee Anthony
here we're humans
we're human beings we've thought about
it
we've thought about it
sure we've I mean everybody thinks about
drowning their kid but we're not gonna
die
but
you know she's sitting there with her
man's
and they're on the bed and he goes why
don't is there something that could
happen in a McDonald's
that would not really
change her life but would make us a lot
of money
and the mother sitting there the mother
smoking a cigarette and
just like I could burn her with a nugget
if I took a nugget and heated it up to
about 200 or 350 like the hottest nugget
ever
and I burn her leg
and then I call McDonald's and I go you
[__] pieces of [__] my daughter has a
second degree burn
do you know how like second degree burns
like a real that's like a decent burn
and I think that's what the mother said
the mother was basically like and this
is by the way I want all immigrants to
be able to do this that's why I'm I want
the immigrants to migrants to be settled
because I want them in 20 years to be
thinking of burning their children with
McNuggets so they consume McDonald's I
want an immigrant woman having a child
and thinking how can I burn my autistic
daughter with a McNugget so I get a
little money in this world how do I come
out ahead
how do I come out ahead here if I don't
burn my daughter with this nugget
just because
it's almost over
mother's pressing the Nugget on her leg
it's almost over look at me
now my autistic daughter cannot talk to
you right now
but she's very upset
than a nugget just came loose from her
bag
and ended up between a seat belt and her
thigh shut up don't don't ask why she's
autistic are you stupid
there was a girl in the backseat of my
car who was African-American and
autistic do you want to ask any more
questions no we don't no we don't uh
we're good on that and a nugget flew out
of her a 200 degree nugget
flew out of her bag and landed on her
leg and then was immediately stuck
between her leg and a seat belt for two
minutes where she suffered a
second-degree burn and now she can't
even look at nuggets and she has
seizures when we go near McDonald's she
just starts shaking
ah it's time to pay up
when that mother is going to be driving
a nice Beamer with the drop top and that
daughter is going to be sitting in the
back
my daughter's gonna be sitting in the
back in just like a big sun Bonnet like
not saying anything and you're going
through McDonald's Again by the way and
the daughter's gonna be like and the
mother's gonna go shut the [__] up
foreign
I know you don't like this place but
that's why we got this car
so I believe that I truly believe that
that's that is and I I I know it's a
comedy show but there is a possibility
that something like that happened
this feels odd
something feels odd here
and I do believe there is a possibility
this mother burned her child with this
nugget and that's why I focused on the
story today because
and I don't judge no one
I don't judge no one on this show
I have not walked a mile in her shoes I
don't know what she's gone through it's
the only way out is to burn your
autistic daughter with a nugget in the
leg
[__] it I don't judge you I might not do
it I might I don't know I might I don't
know where she's at
I don't know where she's at
but I'm telling you right now I don't
judge anyone for their I'm just when
that girl can't speak when that [__]
does start to talk
she's gonna tell us a tale
when that girl starts to talk
what if this girl keeps having [__] done
to her like in a string of bad luck
[Laughter]
in a string of bad luck this girl lost
her eye to a french toast stick at
Burger King
it's amazing because the French toast
stick was so hot that it seared her eyes
shut and now she can't you know she
can't see
and that just happened a year later
odd what if this mother just takes his
girl around a different Florida you know
fast food restaurants in Florida and
maims her every time it's like a
munchausen's by proxy but it's all fast
food
this girl contracted HIV at Pollo
Tropical